oh this fiddler nakamura game yeah
um picaro gave a nice interview about it
okay we're gonna accept random
random sub playing
annex abbess
world of warships oh
do i play a stafford will this be the
most relaxing
stafford gambit of our time
opponent's provision oh opponents okay
decent player
okay no stafford gambit we're gonna have
a oh
oh opponents jeroming me it's like a
premature jerome
oh we transposed into jerome what is
this
what oh no it was three checks
it was three checks what i got i got
debated tricked
why the queen was hanging
ah i feel so broken
i was wondering why white was playing so
dubiously
that was three checks i didn't i i just
assumed it was
normal chess
i'm so broken that's my first is that my
first loss of stream
i think that is
my rating oh that good thing that was
unrated i could have lost a lot of
rating points
do i just sit and cry on the virtual
beach
what did i do wrong
rematch oh let's get revenge now now
that i know it's three check
time for revenge we're gonna show how to
not lose in six moves revenge time
well unless opponent just wants to keep
their perfect score oh wait
we played once before
i guess so the one time we played before
was not in three check
okay time for revenge
so for those who don't know three track
is a variance
where you win the game if you get three
checks
and any points and they're cumulative
and i think the strategy is not to get
checked
so we have a french so if black black's
not going to do this but if
if this were played i would check and
then take again and check
okay we're gonna do this move
i think the t is the t has been brewing
for long enough
hopefully
did i mispronounce q q cumulative
humi i've it's too difficult
okay let's play what to play
i just want some sweet sweet revenge
play this move
what is the brewing time brewing time
oh not recommended for use if you're
pregnant or nursing
or have high blood pressure okay good
thing that doesn't apply to me
okay
okay we're being calm
do i have a favorite album
do people even do albums these days
albums used to be like physical objects
but now they're just
virtual
oh licorice root can give you headaches
it's actually good to know i don't drink
this every day
that's just my tea of choice for tonight
it is nice and sweet and soothing
actually i i grew up uh enjoying
this don mclean
i think the album was called american
pie
but had some good good soundtracks
did you write the book of love
oh i don't i don't really write books
but i was have i told this story
i told this story on um
[Music]
on fiona's talk show for chess 24
but i was actually featured in a romance
novel
a few years ago
so i was in a book that talked about
love
wow it's lying out this is my first time
watching you live but me
and my wife love watching your youtube
shout out to you and your wife
before going to bed i've really gotten
back into chess
because of your vids so oh that's nice
to hear please keep posting and we'll
try and watch
more live streams thanks so much for
that
i hope i didn't disturb you earlier with
the loud sounds
thank you lionex appreciate the kind
words
so uh story time when was this
two years ago two or three years ago
um a a sort of distant
relative or aunt picked up a book
from a library and
in the intro like in the not even what
you call it before the
the actual story starts
the dedication page
the the author mentioned my name
and said it said something like i
i owe a huge shot of gratitude to eric
rosen
and it was a romance novel let's take
upon
such a nice move and
of course my relative like got in touch
with my parents and told
like pass this on and oh it's ch
oh it's check um
and i i had completely forgotten but
back in 2013 an author contacted me
it's like new york times best-selling
author
jack and she was writing like a love
story
about the chess player who attended
the university of illinois and some
somehow she found me online like i was
attending university of illinois at the
time
and she interviewed me and like got a
sense of like what the chess world is
like
ah my queen
and then um
after a few years few years she turned
it into a book
good game there's no stopping
the check all you need is three checks
doesn't matter
the material situation
um so anyway uh
the book the book ended up being a new
york times bestseller
i guess in the romance category it's
called
it's it's not really kid friendly but
it's called the um
the girl he used to know good games
let me see if i can find it oh good
games oxygen gambit
i got my sweet sweet revenge
oh so i um not so the author is tracy
garves graves
and i just googled it uh so you can see
the the thing here
um let me see if i can find it
but there is there is a character
in the book named eric mesopotamia
yeah mesopotamia
uh let me see if i can find this
oh i guess this is proof
maybe i have told this before was
prompted the
question i was not a ghost writer i was
just kind of like a consultant
uh i was just asked like what the the
chess club scene was like
um got the is randomly mentioned in the
book too
but uh
there was some like when i watched
queen's gambit there was some
interesting crossover between
um
[Music]
like the vibe of queen's gamut and the
vibe of this book
uh let me see if i can actually find the
dedication page
oh here it is oh i found it okay
it might be hard to show
okay i don't know how google does this
but this is
um this was like kind of the
the pre-intro to the book
um yeah it mentioned some like true
stories
but yeah here it was
it's on audible too
but it was it was crazy that like i kind
of i had this conversation with with an
author
and then several years later uh
it actually turned into a book
i was not asked to narrate the book
anyway that's my story
thanks for the game again three check
game
anyway if this goes on youtube
thanks youtube people for watching
this will be a really weird youtube
video like i got debated
and then i got revenge and then i told
the story
of how i was featured in a romance novel
all while listening to soothing
calm copyright free music
i'll leave links in the video
description
also twitch chat
say hi to youtube say hi we have blank
canvas twitch chat
good title do you accept this rosen
good title wait what's the title
i don't know if i understand but
i guess it's good if it mentions the
word good
hi nada gm how's it going yeah say hi
twitch chat has been so friendly today
so positive so generous
or daughter and maybe cousin
and say hi to otaki was there talking
somewhere
youtube comments you know what to do
you can just choose a random person to
say hi to
but when in doubt say hi to tagi and a
z payphone z